حلقه كامله نخصصها اليوم لتداعيات زلزال
تركيا والسوريه المدمر وتغريده لباحث
هولندي تفجر نقاشا واسعا حول امكانيه
التنبؤ بالزلازل وهل الذكاء الاصطناعي
قادر على التنبؤ بها وعشرات الاسئله حول
الهزات الارتداديه وخطورتها اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
كارثه طبيعيه بكل المقاييس وقاعات وضربت
بشكل اساسي شمال سوريا وجنوب شرق تركيا
ومتصدر الاخبار والعناوين والترند على كل
منصات والهاشتاقات عنا كمان ماليه تويتر
وفيديوهات القاسيه منتشره بكل مكان على
المنصات طبعا احنا بنتحدث عن الزلزال اللي
ضرب تركيا وسوريا اليوم بقوه 7.8 درجات
على مقياس ريختر ويعتبر الاقوى من عام
1999 في تركيا والاقوى من عام 1905 في
سوريا الزلزال صار في عشر ولايات تركيه
وهي اضنه وغازي عنتاب وديار بكر وهاتاي
واديمن وعثمانيه وعثمانيه وشانلي اورفا
وفي سوريا اصاب ايضا المحافظات اللاذقيه
وحلب وطرطوس وحماه
الشمس وخلف من بعده مئات الهزات
الارتداديه التي وصلت لباقي المناطق
التركيه والمحافظات السوريه وما اقتصرت
عليهم بس لا وصلت الهزات الارتداديه الى
ايران العراق لبنان الاردن ومصر وما زالت
مستمره طوال اليوم ومن ساعات تم الاعلان
عن تسجيل زلزال ثاني جنوب شرق تركيا بقوه
7.5 درجه وصل هذه المره مدى للعاصمه
السوريه دمشق
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
القتلى بالالاف والجرحى اكثر بكثير سواء
في سوريا وتركيا وعمليات الانقاذ لا زالت
مستمره وما توقفت وساعه بعد ساعه بتزيد
اعداد الخسائر البشريه اما الخسائر
الماديه فكما بالالاف تركيا اعلنت انه
للان احصنت دمار ثلاثه الاف مبنى تقريبا
اما سوريا للان ما في احصائيه واضحه لعدد
المباني
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد عمل اجتماع مع
الجهات المعنيه لمساعده المتضررين
والمنكوبين ومن دقائق النظام السوري
الناشد المجتمع الدولي مد يد العون لدعمه
في مواجهه الزلازل وخاصه في ظل الاوضاع
الصعبه اللي بتشهدها البلد هذا غير
الاحوال الجويه اللي بتقارب فيها درجه
الحراره الصفر والرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان هو كمان اجتمع بالقيادات وطلع او
طلع ووجه كلمه للمواطنين
منذ كزس
[موسيقى]
مركزي كهرمان
وطبعا اطقم الانقاذ والاسعاف في سوريا
وتركيا مش ملحقه واللي لوحدها على الكم
الهائل من الضحايا والخسائر ودول العالم
كلها هبت لتقديم المعونه والمساعده بنتكلم
عن الكويت والامارات ومصر والصين وروسيا
واسرائيل وامريكا والاتحاد الاوروبي
واليونان والمانيا واوكرانيا ومن بعد
الماساه هذه تسارعت كثير من الدول العربيه
والغربيه لعرض تقديم مساعدات وفرق انقاذ
للمساعده وحتى تم ارسال اقمار صناعيه لمسح
المناطق المتضرره ومع الصور والمقاطع
والاخبار اللي ماليه المنصات عن الزلزال
في تغريده اللافت الانظار وعامله نقاش
واسع التغريده لباحث الجيولوجيا هولندي
تقال انه او تم تداول انه هو تنبا
بالزلزال من كم يوم التغريده نزلها يوم 3
فبراير وبيقول فيها انه عاجلا ام اجلا في
زلزال بقوه 7.5 راح يضرب منطقه جنوب وسط
تركيا وسوريا والاردن ولبنان
طبعا الزلزال صار من هنا والناس رجعت
للتغريده
واستعرضوها وتداولوها وشاركوها حتى صار
عليها 25 مليون مشاهده وتغيير فجرت
تساؤلات يعني اولها وابرزها هل هو ممكن
اصلا التنبؤ بالزلازل ولو فعليا يمكن
والرجال تنبا وحذر ليه من عمل شيء والفين
اصلا وصل العلم بخصوص التنبؤ بالكوارث
الطبيعيه والاي درجه هذا الشيء بيساعد
الحكومات تكون جاهزه لكوارث من هذا النوع
خلينا نعرف هذه التفاصيل من البروفيسور
نجيب ابو كركي استاذ علم الزلازل في
الجامعه الاردنيه اهلا فيك معانا بروفيسور
حضرتك اكيد طلعت على هذه التغريده هل
تعتبر انه هو تنبا بما سيحدث
في الواقع من وجهه نظر علم الزلازل ابدا
ومن وجهه نظر المنطق ايضا ابدا ابدا لما
نقول انه اجلا ام عاجلا سيحصل سيحصل زلزال
ما معنى هذا يعني عندما نقول اجلا ام
عاجلا سيحصل زداء انا بقول لك الان انه
اجلا او عاجلا كل البشر راح يموتوا هل انا
تنبات بانه تنبؤي صحيح في الواقع
اللي فعلا اصيبت
لو تكرمت لو تكرمتي اذا ظليتي تقاطعيني زي
هيك مش راح توصل الفكره لايناس فلو تكرمتي
خليني اكمل الفكره حتى نستطيع نفهم على
بعض في موضوع ليس سهل
انا اول جمله بس كنت بقول لك اياها انه هو
تنبا بالاماكن الصحيحه فيعني عادي ممكن
تهدي اعصابك شويه ونكمل مع بعض بهدوء
وحنفهم فكرتك اتفضل الان
تمام اي موقع زلزالي انا بقول لك الان
انني يعني لو قلت لك انه ان اجلا ام عاجلا
اي صدع في العالم كل صدوع العالم راح يصير
عليها زلازل فهل ستسجلي اني تنبات
بالزلازل على كل صدوع العالم
هذا كلام يعني من وجهه نظر علم الصفائح
علمه زلازل لا معنى له بتاتا التنبؤ
بالزلازل يحتاج الى ان نحدد مجموعه من
الامور اين سيحصل الزلزال هاي واحد منها
ومواقع الزلازل هي مواقع الصدوع متى سيحصل
الزلزال بالتحديد يعني لاقرب اسبوع مثلا
هذا لم يحصل كم هي قوه الزلزال اللي بتوقع
انه يحصل وكم هي احتماليه ان يكون هذا
التنبؤ صدفه عندما يكون في منطقه بيحصل
فيها كل يوم عشر زلازل اذا قلت انا انه
اليوم راح يحصل فيها زلزال هذا لا يعتبر
تنبا
فحقيقه هذا في الواقع هو عباره عن اشاعه
هدفها اثاره البلبله وها هي قد زبطت منها
بتصير البلبله بشكل جيد ليتنبا لنا بموقع
محدد غير سوريا
وتركيا اللي عمليا انا بعتقد بانهم الى حد
ما مستهدفين من الكثيرين في العالم
هذا يجب ان ننتبه له بشكل جيد ويجب ان لا
نكون ايضا يعني بسيطين وفي في تفكينا
لنحكم العقل والمنطق
وهذا هذه الجمله هي اللي بقول لك اياها
انا اقول لو قلت مثلا ان كل صدع في هذا
العالم سيحصل عليه زلزال ان اجلا ام عاجلا
اي اي تنبؤ هذا طيب بمعزل عن هذه اختصارا
من وجهه نظر علميه اعطيني هل في طريقه او
سبل لتحديد مثلا هذه المعلومات
حقيقه التنبؤ قصير المدى بما يفيد الناس
على اسلوب على سبيل المثال الطقس هذا في
الوقت الحاضر غير ممكن لاي امكانيه علميه
في العالم لكن ان نقول بشكل عام نعرف وانا
بقول لك كمان بقدر اقول لك انه تنبات برضو
في هذا الزلزال كيف كيف على صفحتي على
فيسبوك حطيت نتيجه جريده بتقول عن محاضره
عملتها في 23 في
26/12/1996 عنوانها الزلازل الكبرى تتركز
في ايران وتركيا والقوقاز وهذا الحكي من
سنه 1996 حكي علمي وهو مش مبني على اي
تكهنات مبني على انه هذه هذه الحدود هي
حدود صفائح من النوع التصادمي حصل فيها
سابقا زلازل من هذا النوع ذكر رئيس
الجمهوريه التركيه بانه هذا اكبر اكبر
زلزال منذ 1939 هذا صحيح لانه في 1939 حصل
زلزال قوته ثمانيه
زلزال هذا معروفه بعد ذلك حصل 12 زلزال
فيما بعد حتى 1999 زلزال ازميت اذا هذا
التاريخ لتركيا وما نلاحظ من ملفات
الزلازل بتقول لنا انه لا يمر يعني عمليا
خمس سنوات بدون ما يحصل كارثه كبرى اما في
تركيا او في في ايران وهذا ناتج عن تصادم
الصفيحه العربيه مع الصفيحه الاوروبيه
الاسيويه نعلم ان التصادم في كل مكان في
العالم ينتج اعنف انواع الزلازل واكثرها
تكرارا كما يحصل في اليابان مثلا المشهوره
جدا بهذا المجال وبعض سلاسل الجبال الاخرى
انا حاسه او حابه اني استغل وجودك معانا
واخذ رايك كمان في موضوع اخر اللي هو
موضوع الهزات الارتدادة للزلازل وهذه
بتكون المدمره يعني
فالزلازل اليوم تم رصد مئات مئات الهزات
الارتداديه واللي شعر بيها السكان في
مناطق بعيده الالاء بعيده يعني ناس شعروا
فيها في اماكن بعيده الاف الكيلومترات عن
سوريا وتركيا نحن بنتكلم عن مصر عن الاردن
عن لبنان وحتى في هزات تخيلوا انه رصدت في
جزيره جرينلاند اقصى شمال الكره الارضيه
الاسئله هنا عاد كثيره
وتحديدا عن هذا الموضوع اللي هو عن الهزات
الارتداديه لكن طبعا
يبدو انه انقطع الاتصال مع
خليلنا احنا حنحاول نرجع له في هذه
الاثناء ولكن مشاهدينا هل رجع طيب خلينا
نشاهد اذا الان هذا المقطع ونعود لمواصله
حوارنا
[موسيقى]
طيب نرجع لك ففسر وخلينا نرجع لك من ناحيه
الهزات الارتداديه اول شيء يعني ايش الفرق
بين الهزات الارتداديه هذه والزلازل
في الواقع الهزه الارتداديه هي زلزال انما
حصل في سياق زلزال اكبر منه في نفس
المنطقه اللي حصل فيها يعني ما بنستطيع
نقول انه حصل زلزال في تركيا وحصلت لهزه
ارتداديه في على سبيل المثال اللبنان في
الجغرافيا المنطقه بتكون محدده عمليا
عشرات الكيلومترات اذا كانت زلزال كبير
جدا كما هو الحال هنا يعني يمكن ان نعتبر
هذا على نفس الصدع بنفس البيئه هو عباره
عن هزه ارضيه بتكون عمليا هدفها اعاده
التوازن للمنطقه لانها عندما يحصل بها
زلزال كبير بتكون قد اضطربت بشكل كبير جدا
وفقدت التوازن يعني نفس الغلاف الصخري
فبصير في عنا يعني رغبه او عمليا اتجاه
لاعاده توازن بالهزات الارتداديه في نفس
المنطقه اللي حصلت فيها الزلازل الاولى
لكن زلزال كبير كهذا هذه المنطقه تحدد
يعني بعشرات الكيلومترات على نفس الصدى
لاي درجه بتكون الهزات خطيره
خطوره الهزات يعني بتعتمد اساسا على ايضا
البناء ونوعه والاستعداد وما شابه ذلك في
بعض زلازل الكبرى اكبر اكبر من هذا في
تشيلي مثلا
كان عدد القتلى قليل جدا اثنين ولا ثلاث
لكن في مناطق اخرى من العالم العربي للاسف
الشديد اربعه ونص زلزال بسيط جدا يعني قد
يقتل عشر اشخاص او 12 شخص هذا الزلزال
عمليا عالميا زلزال 87 بالعشره في منطقه
ماهوله مدن مليونيه بتكون خسائر وبعشرات
الالاف عن الهزات الجداديه هل ممكن تكون
الدمار اللي تعمله اسوا يكون من الزلزال
نفسه اللي حتى لدرجه انه نتلخبط بينها
وبين الزلزال
طبعا هذا ممكن رغم ان الهزه الارتداديه
قوتها بالتعريف اقل من الهزه الرئيسيه لكن
عندما يحصل زلزال كبير فهو يهلهل كم كبير
جدا من الابنيه اذا جاءت ضربه اضافيه حتى
وان كانت اضعف من الاولى فتؤدي الى انهيار
ما تبقى يعني من اماكن وقد يكون الدمار
برضو كبير في هذا المجال لانه الابنيه
تهلهلت سابقا واصبحت ضعيفه طيب تم الحديث
عن وجود زلزال ثاني او حدوث زلزال ثاني
اللي هو كان سبعه فاصله خمسه هذا زلزال
يعتبر اخر ولا هزه ارتداديه
الاحتمال الاكبر خاصه اذا كان مكانه يعني
يبعد نسبيا عن هذا المكان ان يكون اشي
مستقل لانه الهزات الارتداديه يعني
علاقات التجريبيه في علم الزلازل بتقول
المفروض يكون في فرق تقريبا واحد واحد
واثنين بالعشره درجه
تكون الهزه الارتداديه اقل من الهزه
الرئيسه لكن هذا برضو هنالك استثناءات
والعلاقه التجريبيه احيانا قد تفشل فما
يحدد انه هز ارتداديه ولا هذه رئيسيه هو
الموقع والظروف واليه الزلزال يمكن حسابها
بواسطه علم الزلازل فيما بعد الانترنت
مليان بالحديث عن تسونامي قادم
ردك على هذا الموضوع
طبعا تسونامي في الواقع يعني ارتفاع مستوى
مياه البحر ومهاجمتها مثلا الشواطئ هذا
يمكن رصده بشكل جيد ولا يمكن التكهم به
جزافا بهذا الشكل في انظمه نظام انذار
مبكر للتسونامي تعتمد على انه بكون هنالك
طوافات في البحر تحدد احداثياته وتحدد
ارتفاعاتها اذا بالاقمار الصناعيه اكتشف
انه فجاه جبهه كبيره من المياه ارتفعت
وهذا يمكن تحديده يعلن انه في هنالك
تسونامي والا يعني لا نستطيع ان نقول انه
تسونامي طبعا تسونامي من من مميزاته
الحميده بانه يعطي وقت قد ياتي بعد ساعات
بعد
يعني فتره طويله وليس كالزلزال لحظي
ومفاجئ نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله بروفيسور كان معنا نجيب ابو كركي
استاذ علم الزلازل في الجامعه الاردنيه
اتمنى اني ما اكون قاطعتك بحيث ازعجتك
شكرا جزيلا شكرا لك شكرا لك
كم من جديد تكلمنا من بدايه او تكلمنا
بدايه الحلقه عن التنبؤ بالزلازل وامكانيه
ذلك علميا اناقشنا الموضوع مع ضيفنا استاذ
علم الزلازل وفي نفس هذا السياق متداول
اون لاين الكثير من المقالات عن برمجيات
ذكاء اصطناعي قيل انه عندها القدره على
التنبؤ بالزلازل واحسن من العلم والبشر
لكن لاي درجه هذا الكلام دقيق احنا حبينا
نتاكد وسالنا دكتور محمد قاسم صديقنا طبعا
في البرنامج علشان يجاوبنا على هذا
الموضوع
اهلا يا ساره واهلا في الساده والسيدات
المشاهدين بالنسبه للذكاء الاصطناعي
والتنبؤ بالزلازل الاوراق العلميه كثيره
في هذا الجانب لكن ان تاخذ الاوراق
العلميه وتطبقها وتاتي بالنتائج منطقيه
مقبوله فهذا امر صعب التنبؤ في الزلازل
يعتبر مثل التنبؤ بحاله الطقس او مثلا
التنبؤ بالاسهم وما شابه من الصعب جدا
الوصول الى نتائج دقيقه في هذا الموضوع
ممكن يوصون الى نتائج مقاربه للصحه ولكن
لن تكون دقيقه ابدا التنبؤ في المستقبل
امر شبه مستحيل الان المشكله الاساسيه في
هذا الموضوع هي ليست ان هل هناك قدره في
التنبؤ وحتى لو كانت 99% لنفترض ان هناك
ذكاء اصطناعي استطاع ان يتنبا بقدره 99%
هل من الممكن ان الحكومات تتبنى وتستخدمها
في الانذار المبكر هنا المعضله لان
المشكله وين ان الاقتصاد يعتمد على مثل
هذه الاشياء اذا تنبا الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحدود زلزال قريبا
هل الناس عندهم الاستعداد لاقفال محلاتهم
هل الحكومه عندها استعداد ان يذهب الناس
في حاله من الهلع والركض وترك اعمالهم
وذهاب للمنزل والخروج من اخراج كل شيء فيه
هل الحكومه عندها الاستعداد ان تتحمل هذا
كله ثم بعد ذلك بما ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
الى اليوم غير قادر على التنبؤ في وقت
حدوث الزلزال هو غير قادر على التنبؤ حتى
في مكان الزلزال فتخيلي المستقبل انه يعلن
عن زلزال ولا يعرف بالضبط اين سيكون فتؤخذ
دائره كبيره من مساحه الارض للتنبع
فعدد كبير من الناس يتوقف اعمالهم عدد
كبير من الناس يخافون وينزعجون ويضطرون
للخروج وما شابه فهذه تسبب اشكاليه
اشكاليه من ناحيه القانون اشكاليه من
ناحيه الاخلاق اشكاليه من ناحيه كيف
تتعامل معها الحكومه وهل لرئيس دوله عند
الاستعداد ان يضحي حتى الحكومه ان تضحي
بسمعتها من اجل ان تصدر
اعلان بهذا الشكل ولا لا هذا الموضوع طبعا
امر يحتاج الى دراسه طويله ويحتاج الى دقه
كبيره جدا
لم نحصل عليها الى الان سواء من ذكاء
الاصطناعي او غيره من الادوات
مع مجموعه من اللحظات المؤثره لالتقطتها
كاميرات لتبعاد زلزال تركيا وسوريا وعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله الله يرحم
الضحايا ويشفي المصابين ويخفف عن العالقين
تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]